[Music]
have you guys experienced zoom fatigue
what is that zoom enough zoom
I did a zoom party with my friends where
we all did PowerPoint presentations very
fun are you wearing the same yeah I was
not wearing the suit i this is before
the rear aunt this is five days ago what
zoom zooming too much
yeah the zoom use in like facetiming and
stuff it went up 200% whoa and now it's
time to die down well no it's not that
it's more about like exploring like the
psychological effects of zooming all the
time and not necessarily has to be on
the zoom app is just the fact that your
face timing like non-stop you're
conferencing oh it's good to be the
company zoom then they take their name
and branded the whole webcaming thing
Ezio that webcams are sold out
everywhere ready yeah you know what's
funny is already so people thought that
zoom was gonna go up in stocks right and
a lot of people invested into the wrong
zoom company really and blew that up
yeah it's [ __ ] funny so the people
that were invested into that company
they were like oh [ __ ] and they sold
their stock and when people realized
that that wasn't the same zoom the stock
plummeted [ __ ] all the time
it's another company with zoom they're
both called zoom which was the legal the
legal papers well illegal zoom legal oh
yeah I don't know what the other company
is but it's a it's a it's there was a
graph yeah this is the the zoom the
webcam zoom one right and and this is
the other zoom company that a lot of
people invested yes they thought they
were getting into this do you know think
some dumb [ __ ] like this the 80s was
like I eat [ __ ] tons of apples all by
Apple stops and then the multi
multi-millionaire right now accidentally
someone's gotta have that somebody right
now yeah we got so this fatigue that
they're talking about because a lot of
people have been vocal about about it on
the internet like like is anyone else
getting like really really tired from
like constant videoconferencing and like
because a lot of people they had to do
it for work there's a lot of like zoom
meetings and then after work then
there's or like a group like conference
kind of meetings so then there's that or
there's like a one-on-one meeting and
that like after you're done with work
and stuff then you have to jump on a
call for with friends or five she
connect with friends and family and like
all this videoconferencing a lot of
people are expressing that they feel
like fatigue there's many of the people
that have to work a lot in person and
since they can't do that anymore they
have to work a lot through soon yeah
like most of their lives are just
meetings yeah like that I wonder why
they can't call I think it's the same
effect right yes are you getting tired
of this kind of like electronic
conversation I feel like it's like that
when you're zooming or your face timing
you see yourself kind of thing and
you're kind of self-conscious of like oh
you look or whatever so there's a
constant like need to like address that
situation whereas aren't we're on the
phone you could be [ __ ] jacking off
yeah and no one knows that you know
you're just chilling I don't know if I
was yeah yeah yeah me too leave the
camera have you done that no yeah and
then yeah but yeah you're right can you
say that again but like Moni do me duele
clean guys dick suck on the phone Wow he
was talking like president of another
country from Monica Lewinsky
yeah and she sounds like he's always
having to orgasm anyways so he's like
the presidential version of like
roadhead yeah it's gotta be right you
had like you know you're getting head
while you're driving like how the [ __ ]
do you focus on that and focus on that
and it's just like the exhilaration of
like oh my god I can die anything do you
really have to focus you're on the phone
with the prime minister of Lithuania if
you had these kind of phones oh [ __ ]
they've been getting head for a long
time but if anyone should be gating
phone head it should be the president
because they don't have much time no
yeah that's Maximizer schedule and what
if you just had to do a drone strike or
something and then he's stressed and so
relaxed relief well this is just before
all that but yeah oh that's true you
think what the President does a drone
strike they put the ear to the window to
hear if they could hear what happened
the White House just wishful thinking
for them so zoom fatigue stuff so like
Casey said it it does have a lot to do
with that from the insecurities I mean I
guess you could call that self-awareness
I guess self-awareness because of that
so okay you know how we're on right now
like literally like we turn it on
because we're in front of a camera like
we're doing our jobs right right now to
be a personality yeah that's what a lot
of people are experiencing on their day
to day that are used to this so you know
what JK news feels like [ __ ] hey
look you work so hard now they know what
it's like no I mean I mean like the fact
that like it's like psychologically like
you are like it's mentally stimulating
or whatever like you have to think
really hard and like be very self aware
like oh how am i coming off cuz I'm in a
group chat with a whole bunch of people
everyone can see everyone like how do I
come off like it's like being extra
present like to present exactly so it's
like mentally draining for a lot of
people that I don't they start going
doing [ __ ] like this on their work call
yeah yeah that's why these guys are so
good at it cuz they're never self-aware
true so self-aware that we're executing
it in a way that you can't see the
execution the guys you can't see the
performance that's called pulling
strings my friend I would you spilled
your coffee all was so hot I almost did
I grabbed it like this - I was like hope
dude it's hot you gotta touch it from
the mug
it was hot people are saying like they
were recommending ways to alleviate zum
fatigue and jacking off well the obvious
suggestion here is to limit video calls
to only those that are necessary stop
looking at yourself you could can't you
just take out your screen yeah you can
turn off your book you're looking at
yourself another recommendation is where
you could just turn your video off and
still be involved in the in the meeting
or limit those video calls and try to
condense whatever information so it's
like not like there's no information
saturation when you use emails like just
use an email to communicate you don't
necessarily have to see face it's like
see each other that's my [ __ ] right
there
I prefer that to be honest like at least
an energy I'm like you wasted one hour
of my time when you could have [ __ ]
told me in a sentence in an email or a
text after that I said [ __ ] Hollywood
agents oh they do dude it's 45 minutes
of hey how you been how awesome you are
and on top of that who they've worked
with that's so famous and awesome and
then 10 to 15 minutes of the actual
conversation [ __ ] the business oh my
gosh yeah I've had I've had jobs like
that clients like that way they're like
I'll be on the phone for a whole hour
and they're just building up their
product for the longest time telling me
about who they work with and who they
might work with in the future they're
like yeah we had this company look at us
we had this we had this company look at
us it's me so good and at the end of it
they tell me this one thing they needed
to tell me which took 30 seconds but the
trouble is you excited about the oh I
don't care
God just said I do that
the width the reason why I said that is
pre 2020 when I was a little bit I think
less emotionally intelligent 2020
yeah so pre like just three months ago
help me with my emotional intelligence a
lot so I couldn't even read people I
can't even understand like I was a
complete robot right yeah so I would be
like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] but then
now because of Steve helping me with my
emotional intelligence like when I when
I hear stuff like that I hear
duplicating amped-up I'm like what I
hear now is it this is a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] wasting my time I go
wow this guy's really excited about his
project they need hopes that I'm just as
excited about his project too so if I
can give them and reciprocate that do
this is so [ __ ] don't be a let's do
it now he gets to hang up going oh cool
like III have someone else on my team so
that's how I hear it now versus
obviously I think anyone can go hey can
you just do this for me but then it's
that's like the most boring sex that you
can have right so what you're trying to
do is try and get everyone on board and
so we're all app high fives all around
how many high fives can we get you play
the game I just [ __ ] hate the game
but he's so didn't getting so good now
cuz like even two months ago you would
he would be like guys pitching a bunch
of [ __ ] or whatever and then Bart
gets off the phone and Geo's like who
was that he's like oh this guy he's
excited about all the [ __ ] so it's
like the only thing that changed was now
Bart plays the game or before he's just
sitting there like hey can you just
condense it in the email okay bye but I
understand it and I feel it now you
listen I'm not just aware of the game
actually empathize for why because I
they just so happen to meet the wrong
person but I think 99% of the world
actually operate this really hey you
want to watch a movie I want to watch
the movie what movie do you want to
watch that's watched it so but I think
majority of the world that's how they
work right most people don't go hey you
want to watch a movie i here's already a
thousand movies i've been willing to
watch it pick one yeah sure that's my
style everything is already premeditated
predetermined I know what I want to do
that's yes exactly that's the minority
of the world so for me like if you don't
speak something that excites me in the
first sentence shut the [ __ ] up but now
I understand most people are talking and
figure it out on the fly so I get that
now
the beauty of UW works on themselves
like you do and and I was just joking
with you yesterday that because we were
making we're all doing jokes about how
funny would be to watch you have sex
because you you probably have the same
face yeah and then she said that I was
like bar Quan is the only guy in the
world word you could give him that note
and then tomorrow morning you'll see him
in the mirror like working on a sec yeah
probably what is endearing yeah I put
the camera angle right here just like
and get her view her perspective that
what is it give her a survey afterwards
yeah how well you did have that time and
what facial reaction you like that what
moment you could replicate that every
single time is it great because he just
has so much to work on he does but he is
such a good robot now takes time to
learn you know what's crazy
I took a online I took a online
Asperger's quiz and they said I'm very
high on the spectrum did you take it
again so you could get a better score
[Laughter]
out of this I'm gonna try to see a
psychologist cuz I feel like because
like all the questions are asking like
me hearing it in third person and
thinking about myself as not myself I'm
like this guy is ridiculous but the one
I'm he as I'm hearing it I'm like [ __ ]
this is all on me so what the [ __ ] am I
because I can relate completely with
Bart and understand but at the same time
I don't think we're quite the same he's
like a bead a B Asperger's student and
you're like a d-plus and Bart's is gonna
study for the next test and Paulie
gettin a still just be a deep pocket
[Laughter]
[Music]